we're gonna start with Obamacare because
everybody's freaking out they should
have used Squarespace which is what I
told them in the first place the website
is not working and just to catch you up
real quick
the government's back to work or
whatever it is that they do remember
they shut down for about three weeks
because the House GOP didn't really want
for people to have health insurance
because that would destroy freedom the
way I understand it and now people are
freaking because the website is not
working out and Kathleen Sebelius who is
the Health and Human Services director I
think director she was on CNN with
Sanjay Gupta last night explaining some
of the problems
let's take a look did say that he was
angry about this I mean do you know when
he first knew that there was a problem
well I think it became clear fairly
early on the first couple of days not
before that though not before October
1st there was no concern at that point
in the White House or at HHS I think
that we talked about having testing
going forward and if we had an ideal
situation and could have built a product
and you know a five-year period of time
we probably would have taken five years
but we didn't have five years and
certainly Americans who rely on health
coverage didn't have five years for us
to wait we wanted to make sure we made
good on this final implementation of the
law and again people can sign up call
center is open for business we've had a
million 100,000 calls we've had 19
million people visit the website 500,000
accounts created and people are shopping
every day so people are signing up and
there's health in neighborhoods around
the country that people can have a
one-on-one visit with a trained
navigator and figure out how to sign up
so people are able to sign up all right
so there's a lot of just typical PRBS
there I mean she's just given you
answers that kinda maybe seem true I
thought the one thing that was really
interesting she said 1.1 million calls
to the center 19 million visits to the
website 500,000 accounts created as if
that was good does that seem like a lot
if 19 million people you guys are web
people
80 million people went there dude only
500,000 mean to subscribe I mean is it
that doesn't that show that something's
not what that's a horribly low number I
think they must the government must
abide by Facebook's internal motto that
done is better than perfect clear yeah
clearly they were happy with the way but
it's a hard site to put together to I
mean it's it this is a big a big project
that we're taking on so we have to do we
have to give a little bit of credit and
say a little wiggle room and that thing
to be able to just launch it right away
absolutely I'm willing to go with the
with the wiggle room okay well because
you know the next thing that she said
was that we're gonna bring in our a team
to fix this so who did they bring in to
start this again
I got two web tech savvy technological
people here who do you think they
brought in in the first place yeah it
was mr. t why wasn't the a-team coming
in at the first place I'll write the
question now bring them in now but so
we'll see you know it's the geniuses
coming in yeah apparently like what what
I gleaned from that is that they've been
using the same sort of technology
contractors for a really long time and
it's not sort of lazy and their ability
to code or something like that they just
haven't stayed up to date on current
technologies which is kind of you know
awful yeah I think contractors from like
1992 what are you guys making this thing
about where she said you know we have if
we had five years to do this it would
have been a lot better but people need
health insurance
I mean they had at least a year really
how long does it take I'm willing to
grant them that this is a big project
but how long does it take to get a
website up and running and I think you
know I mean it is a big project but you
know let's be honest - it is just sort
of a sign-up form in the end so do you
want to give everybody sort of the
benefit of the doubt but it is kind of a
say even if you just redirected them to
another site and then collected that
little piece of information yeah I I
don't know I want to give him the
benefit of the doubt but at the same
time it's I mean riot could have built
the technology for they should we should
have it it would be a good contrast how
many web people do you have I've got one
genius yeah you're gonna done it but I
need him so the government could pull
like an eminent domain thing right at
the only upfront is good but don't tell
them that yeah but I mean really know it
we're joking about it but I mean if you
think about it there are porn sites that
are streaming video all day long
literally
millions and millions of videos all day
long and they don't crash so isn't this
like the worst thing that could have
happened to Obama that that something
that he his whole signature policy is
proving to just unravel right right in
front of it yes
it's genius at that you bring that up
and porn has always typically push the
envelope forward technologically yeah so
it's fun maybe that's the 18 the porn
sites crash now because all the tech guy
yeah just make my house in the valley
yeah exactly people behind pornhub yeah
how do I know porn huh I've read about
it
okay never crashes yeah ever what do you
guys think about this idea where she
said that you know it's it's now come
out that they knew for days that this
thing was crashing but that nobody told
Obama she said in that clip that we just
saw nobody told him for a couple days
that this was happening do you think
they purposely
don't tell him anything because I feel
like this has been sort of a consistent
thing so he can be like well I didn't
know so it's not my fault so I feel like
it's sort of like an Independence Day
remember when they didn't tell the
president Pullman about the aliens
because it was plausible deniability I
feel like they do a lot of that with
Obama whose job would it be to tell him
though because nobody wants maybe they
just said who wants to go tell the
president nobody knows nobody does want
to make that make that call go down to
the office knock on the door and say you
know the websites not working right but
she shouldn't that guy at least be fired
the guy that's supposed to tell him like
like how does that stuff not get to the
top well I mean this is one of the great
initiatives of his campaign yeah but
like you'd think that he would be a beta
tester yeah yeah but no beta testing
they didn't even get that far no all
right but so so last question on this
how much of a big deal should we make
this I mean this thing this thing look
this is gonna change the way America is
for the near future in probably for the
long-term future
so should we grant them just alright a
couple weeks of websites grooviness
or is this really a precursor to how the
whole program yeah you know I think it's
such an exciting thing that there's
gonna be a lot of Americans who had
never had health care before so for me
it's like III don't want it to
overshadow the fact that this is a
really great moment in our history where
people who had never been covered before
are about to get covered so I'm going to
at some time I think that the detractors
certainly wanted something like this to
happen because it's easy for them to say
look we told you it doesn't work but you
know websites crash all the time my
website crashes when we get insane
amounts of traffic when we're doing this
probably it's gonna crash as you see the
breakdown I'm giving it the benefit of
the doubt that's my that's my take yeah
I agree with bridge I think that
uninsured Americans have waited long
enough for it I think that like for them
to work out the kinks you know it's it's
it'll be worth the wait yeah all right
and final thought on this you know the
the shutdown apparently costs twenty
four billion dollars to our economy so
maybe we could have used a little bit of
that money for better web programmers
hey guys don't forget the Reuben Reports
brought to you by Cooper com they've got
up to 75% off pet treats toys and more
and if you use code RR you can get
another 20% off that's a lot off there
is a link in the description right down
below code RR 20% off make your pet
happy